Amateur hour that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now in a small community North Dighton
Massachusetts the feds showed up in full
gear they even brought an armored
vehicle all to take into custody a lone
scrawny 21 year old Air Force National
guardsman
today the justice department arrested
Jack Douglas to Shara in connection with
an investigation into alleged
unauthorized removal retention and
transmission of classified National
Defense information
Tashara is an employee of the United
States Air Force National Guard
we will share more information at the
appropriate time
angle will share more information
and provide some much needed context
first let's understand what the bite
Administration is trying to do here
it's somehow trying to turn one of the
worst intelligence breaches of the past
two decades
into a political win for themselves
now let's debunk this and explain it
well today they hope to win competency
points by the fact that they move so
quickly to arrest the leaker
of a big deal the documents had been
online for months on a platform called
Discord and plus it looks like the New
York Times somehow managed to make
contact with the alleged leaker before
our own government
the first trunks were photographed among
hunting equipment these ones were
photographed in a different location on
a Grannis countertop using the gaming
profiles we were able to find
connections with other more popular
social media websites which of course
had family photographs uh online
including that counter that countertop
that granite countertop
well even the Democrat ranking member
the house Intel committee it wasn't
buying it
the New York Times beat the FBI a 21
year old uh uh kid Air National
Guardsman who was trying to impress his
friends clearly there's an awful lot of
work a lot a lot of congressional
oversight work we need to do to fix
these systems that are constantly
allowing or at least regularly allowing
our secrets to get out into the wild how
was he able to print them out how was he
be able to how is he able to remove them
from a secure facility
the facts here are so bad for the Biden
Intel community that even CNN's Jake
Tapper can't hide his disgust
this classified information was
reportedly on Discord for months how
many tens of billions of dollars the U.S
intelligence Community gets each year
from the American taxpayer but it really
seems like there's there was a a lot of
people dropped the ball here it's not a
proud period for the intelligence
Community let's say that
well that's right and it's an
understatement just think of the
debacles of the past few months
like that Chinese balloon that floated
over sensitive sites which this
Administration assured us all was no big
deal
the president doesn't regret the the way
that we handled the first balloon it's
not a major breach
it was just 10 days ago that we learned
that the what the angle had suspected
all along that the Intel intelligence
that China collected was mostly from
electronic signals which can be picked
up from weapon systems or include
Communications from base personnel
oh that's all no big deal now don't
forget the administration wanted
everyone to think they were wise they
were so pragmatic and prudent to blow
the balloon up over the Atlantic
we wanted to wait until it was over
water so that we could mitigate any
potential civilian harm or property
damage
well my goodness how the Chinese must be
pinching themselves right now
and now this damaged the United States
um are finding that it's not that hard
to get this information leak it uh and
put our national security officials in a
really difficult position this is
embarrassing it's bad
the Biden people know they're in trouble
here so look for them to focus maybe on
the biography of the leaker he likes
guns he's anti-big government
he was a young charismatic Man Who Loved
nature God Who Loved shooting guns and
and racing cars a young gun
was described worked on a military base
and is a quote young charismatic gun
enthusiast he had a very dark view of
the intelligence Community very
suspicious of government overreach
well this is perfect in a way for the
bite administration because just as with
their January 6th narrative their goal
is to Brand conservatism and Trump
supporters as not just toxic but as
traitors
now once again just as with the faux
Insurrection the White House and the FBI
are just trying to score political
points and distract us from reality
obviously to the extent that Mr tashera
broke the law he should be punished
completely
but this significant breach pulled the
curtain back on the Amateur hour that is
Biden's foreign policy shop and along
with that his National Security
apparatus
now remember what the leaked documents
told us about Ukraine far different from
the rosy analysis that we got just a few
months ago
and what did we learn about China's role
again
not what we were told by the White House
or the Pentagon
we haven't seen
any confirmation or indication that the
Chinese have provided lethal weapons
lethal capabilities to the Russian
Ministry of Defense throughout this
conflict
did he know that was false when he was
saying it
well the truth is we're not hearing the
truth maybe the 21 year old's view of
the Intel Community isn't far off
the American public has every right to
know the truth about what they're
getting for their 200 billion and
Counting commitment to Ukraine
if the prognosis for victory is grim we
should all know it if China is back
channeling lethal Aid to Ukraine we
should know that
this is information that Americans
actually may vote on in 2024.
like that despite billions in Aid to
Egypt over the years they were planning
to secretly arm Russia With Rockets
like the information that while Biden is
placating China they've tested and
deployed deployed a new longer range
Hypersonic missile that's probably able
to evade U.S defenses
but perhaps even more important than all
of this this intelligence breach shows
us how vulnerable we become
if a 21 year old with no special
training could do this much damage go
unnoticed for this long
Lord only knows what secrets of ours the
Chinese have
as the Associated Press put it
the suspect's arrest is bound to raise
questions about how the highest profile
Intel leak in years one that continues
to unfold with almost daily Revelations
of Highly classified documents could
have been caused by such a young
low-ranking service member
now also worth noting is that in some
circles Mr tashera would be lauded as a
whistleblower
well he revealed vital info that was
hidden from the public which could have
huge political implications
and we certainly know that Democrats in
the Press they love to celebrate certain
types of whistleblowers
what I would like to see more of these
people do is what vinman had the courage
to do the guts to do Lieutenant Colonel
bidman showing Courage the courage to
stand up to the most powerful person in
the world Anonymous did the right thing
by at least telling us that people are
are keeping a Keen Eye on the aberrant
behavior of the president I think
Anonymous is a hero
of course liberals have a double
standard here that's hardly news at this
point but let's not get distracted
our focus should be what do these leaks
mean for our long-term survival as a
nation
are we really even a superpower if some
of our most sensitive military Secrets
can be posted on a public server for
weeks months without officials even
knowing
and are we really even a superpower if
our own Secretary of Defense
sounds this out to lunch when the breach
happened
I I don't know if there are other
documents that are that have been online
before they were somewhere in the in the
web uh and uh and where exactly and who
had access at that point uh we we don't
know
they were in the web
well no one should be surprised if the
Biden team tries to gloss over this
entire sad Saga by arguing that this is
just one bad guy who was maybe
radicalized and an all-male right-wing
chat room
but given how the Biden Administration
has weaponized the Intel agencies
misrepresented key national security
questions and left us vulnerable to
spies and to hackers
why should Americans have faith in
anything they do or say going forward
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else